[Musique]
j'ai la brèche est un père noël en
retard jean richard tard enfin on fait
ce qu'on peut
la bonne idée est là oui d'autant qu' il
faut le dire vous avez eu la gentillesse
de venir marseille pour un jour vous ne
vouliez pas que votre cirque y
séjournent pendant toutes les fêtes sans
vous c'est à dire que chaque fois que je
peux venir aussi que je viens mais en ce
moment je suis en train de changer de
faire une tournée théâtrale qui
m'amènera à marseille d'ailleurs le 11
février date
je dois dire que j'ai un peu abandonné
le cirque mon travail et je reviens à
mes premières amours toujours mes
premières amours et sociale je suis pas
tout le temps mais c'est sans doute ce
qui me passionne le plus car tout ce que
j'ai fait dans la vie au concept foire
il va essayer de faire du cirque et
surtout du bon circuit parce que c'est
ce qu'il faut faire du droit
alors comment les choses se sont passées
là j'aimerais que vous me racontiez par
exemple votre première acquisition en
matière d'animation c'est très compliqué
parce que moi je sais dans la vie je
fais toujours ce que je veux moi je
m'amuse bout
les gens disent pour les jamais de
vacances font erreur je suis toujours en
vacances
l'art l'art dans la vie c'est de faire
ce qui vous amuse toujours voulu avoir
un cirque secrètement mais je fais
jamais les choses moi je vais jamais on
dit que la ligne droite et le le plus
court chemin pour les 1 point à un autre
moi j'ai toujours pris des chemins
le cirque pour moi c'était d'abord le
zoo les animaux chez moi et tout petit à
petit rentrée des émissions de
télévision
et puis un jour enfin il ya deux ans mon
fils mon vrai sirh
alors la bonne chapiteau j'aimerais que
le directeur m'expliquer comment il
monte son spectacle l'image c'est le
cirque c'est cet aspect tactique on
monte je ne vous parlerai pas du
spectacle de 1971 150 bêtes
vous parlez totalement du spectacle de
1972 parce que vous savez le cirque le
cirque le cirque traverse une crise ce
qui fait que les très grands numéros de
cirque existe
mais qui sont très demandés parce qu'il
y en a pas tellement et que quand on
veut faire un spectacle de cirque il
faut c'est prendre deux trois ans à l'as
vence pour les jets cette année j'ai
parlé contre les îles beyrouth qu'ici ça
monsieur comme gilbert hook tous les
cirques du monde voudrait
[Musique]
et
il ya les emiliano en l'air
[Musique]
et à la cavalerie goût russes enfin je
veux dire par là que des choses que l an
prochain gélébart you ce sont des clones
que j'ai dans mes émissions télévisées
mais ce sens qu'on ne vient pas que moi
sur la place ils sont très demandés
[Musique]
oui
e
alors pendant que nous interviewons
jeanrichard de vence était splendide
pachydermes
le spectacle se poursuit à marseille une
fois de dollars est pratiquement jamais
si on va s'arrêter marseille c'est la
célèbre boucle et cette année on reparle
11 mars pour la tournée 1971 on remette
tout en europe 1 tout en a fait tout
avec un nouveau un arrêt dans le midi
jusqu'à non à l'an prochain ah oui
totalement la côte d'azur l'été une
année l'athlète le voudra sur une année
la santé qu'une allée la côte d'azur
non pour chasser vous alors je pensé que
puisque nous sommes entre la noël et
jour de l'an c'est c'est un peu la
période non pas des miracles mais enfin
des souhaits
or je crois que je peux être
l'interprète de tous les spectateurs en
10 ans et pourquoi dans ce spectacle ce
soir marseille le verrions nous pas jean
richard qui sait qui c'est
[Musique]
oui